even guys come up to me and go why are
you why are you doing 30 year old i said
what you wouldn't do when you're 59. you
did good answer what'd you want to do
you went 30 year old or shot then yeah
hi i'm shine reynolds and i'm still on
the lookout i've had some good dates i'm
liking my views that you know i'm saying
it's all good right now child mourinho
and i've had some bad dates how do you
think you've done on the date i don't
really give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna lie
about it where are all the decent men
not in my dms that's for sure you get me
i feel like i'm rolling with the man
then what's going on about your fives it
seems like a lot of men don't know how
to treat a lady i'll just manhandle
everything and this girl's putting a
chest and chest in the nut like geez
will i have better luck this season what
would you do if my ex was after you he
can have you let's find out this
is grilling
my name's wayne lineker and i'm here
because you asked me to come on the show
and i'm here to date the beautiful
cheyenne yeah i'm used to a few
grillings that you know the breasts have
been at me for years but
um
never had so much
grilling on a date before so let's see
what happens but um i think i can handle
it would you expect a lady on a first
date just to be polite
manners not eat with a mouthful but
first of all
manners and decorum do you go on a lot
of first dates not really i think i've
only been on about
3740 dates in my time
not too many then no not no not many i'm
always ready
i was born ready game on
hello
looking bro beautiful babe thank you
what's your name
wayne hello wayne oh he looks really
nice he's made a bit of an effort how
old are you if you don't mind me asking
i'm still a baby babe how's the baby
twice your age twice my age really yeah
to be honest i'm shocked because i
didn't think i'd be
attracted to her but uh
i am so where are you from oh i live in
ibiza but um i based myself in london in
the winters well really close to central
what's the difference between being an
ib far and over here a lot
a lot sunshine
vibes
beautiful soulful place i'll be there
yeah i do enjoy my winter in london
and then uh and then we go party in the
summer yeah okay so how long do you
party for 2012 i did i had
150 hangovers in 150 days
what yeah well actually it was a it was
it was 110 hangovers in 110 days this is
definition of a party boy
wayne lineker but that was a
particularly special year it was the
year ocean opened and i was a little bit
loose then yeah
i've straightened myself out getting
yourself out now so what's straightened
yourself out now then i don't know just
my family i guess and uh i've got
grandchildren now and uh yeah they're
beautiful would you say you're a family
man 100 yeah yeah what makes you a
family man i just love my family we i
love my family holidays together yeah
we've got a very special bond and uh
we're very very close and very tight
yeah yeah okay it's a family man
dick
wait that tick was backwards so what's
your type when um have you got a mirror
my type is that generally mixed race
quite like the thai look you know um
but all my previous girlfriends are
mixed rice my last one um
danielle sundu was half indian
wait so mixed raise five foot five i'm
his dream woman is it your type my types
personality so we'll see we have to see
how the date goes so how many
girlfriends have you had
quite a lot how many is quite a lot
i'm not an
in and out immediate in and out a
relationship guy you know i like to give
it a go um but they seem to have a four
year lifespan is that it yeah but it's
very difficult for girls with my with my
industry and my job and etc is this hugh
hefner definitely a playboy especially
when i was at a younger age it was like
because i was a little bit like say a
bit loose then really so would you like
a bit of a playboy not really playable
just about having a good time you know
going out and enjoying myself you know
i've never been a cheater never cheated
on a woman in my life never cheating on
a woman and i never will know that's
really cool cheers to that yeah cheers
that's a big green tick he's loyal so
i'm guessing
you have a lot of women that like you
for your lifestyle do they like me for
my lifestyle do that or do they admire
me for what i've done
or do they hang on to me for my money um
which is not not that much of that
anymore because they're kind of but yeah
but yeah i think i think women are
attracted to success and i guess in
their eyes i have been quite successful
so how do you filter through what woman
is like dating you for you yeah i mean i
made mistakes in the past you know but
i've seem to have uh filtered them out
now and um i can you know after even the
first date i'm sort of engaging in
what they really want you know you just
got to keep your eye on
their eyes and their personality and
then you'll work out what they really
want you can't trust them all boys be
careful i just think if a woman's
well-mannered and speaks well eats well
you know a good understanding of food
and wine and
you know that's that's that's my bag you
know i like i like that i like a bit of
class and a girl and intelligence as
well you know i like an intelligent
woman but if you're if you're partying
all the time how would you find an
intelligent woman surely she's just
drunk and smashed and can't really get a
good comment you only see that on
instagram don't you only see the party
side on instagram you don't see the
reality you know when you're when you're
spending time together going to a better
town and going shopping and the stuff i
like to do
you know it's not it's not all about
party for me the last thing i want is a
complete party girl really yeah
otherwise that's just a disaster mr
ibiza doesn't want to party girl
obviously i'm going to enjoy myself with
her but there's not going to be any
longevity in it because you know what
ibiza's like and um
it'll just get it just gets tiring
really oh how do you find like
relationships if obviously you're going
around women in bikinis all the time how
does that put pressure on a relationship
or does it yeah of course it does yeah i
mean i like to spend every second of my
day with mark with my girlfriend you
know with my ex she landed a big
modelling job which meant she was then
tied to the uk
she couldn't really travel
which caused problems in the
relationship obviously with me being
ibiza and her being in london
you know me being surrounded by girls
and bikinis every day it's very
difficult for us yeah so eventually the
pressure took it took its toll and um we
parted ways but we're best friends we're
you know we speak every single week
every most days finally someone's
actually friends with their ex like he
actually gets it so you could be friends
with an ex i'm best friends with all my
exes oh my gosh i'm like finally someone
actually gets it all of them oh wow
we're all really really close that's
really interesting yeah i just feel it's
it's nice you know why
because i've i've nev we've never ended
on bad terms it's always been uh sort of
a an agreement between us that time has
passed and uh we'll move on did that
come with aedra have you always just
been like that just always been like
that you know i like good vibes you know
gvo good vibes only i like that and um
yeah i'm just a happy-go-lucky guy you
know is it you that usually breaks up
with them or do they break up with you
it's normally we we we both understand
when the times come but like i say it's
very difficult with my relationship with
my business and
for me to hold on to a strong
relationship for a long period of time
i'm at the stage now where i'm ready for
that and uh
you know i've done all my partying um i
mean there's still a lot more left in me
oh yeah how much more then yeah quite a
lot but so i'm probably gonna go from
seven days a week to six but so that's
fine that's a lot
joking no but i mean i have to go to
ocean people like to see me there and i
love to be there it's my pride and joy
it's it's just difficult for girls to
get their head around sometimes yeah
because i've got hindus all
how do you like kind of have to turn
women down in that sense if women are
throwing themselves at you i mean
they're not throwing themselves at me in
that way they're just having a bit of
banter with me because i'm i'm probably
on every girl's i'll be the whatsapp
groups and stuff like that so i'll come
over and i'm laughing and um yeah it's
just a laugh you know but um it's never
a case of their throwing itself at me to
[ __ ] go around the back and have sex
you know it's not like that yeah see if
we went whoa would you just be like yeah
absolutely no definitely not no it's not
me it's not my bag even when you were
younger no i've never been in my bucket
wayne how many people have you slept
with not that many to be honest not that
many
really you'd think a lot more but it's
just not my bag babe i just don't so how
many is not that many though yeah body
count i wasn't expecting that you know
because i've never kept a number but
that's a bit personal
it's probably a lot compared to most
so what is it it's below 100 anyway
below 100.
more than 50.
i would say around that figure it's
interesting but i'm not one to count if
i'd slept with over 50 men would you
sleep with me i was just gonna ask you
actually would it be an issue for you i
i always say whatever your past is is
your past you know from the day you met
me for example then that's when your
future begins and whatever's happened in
your past is happening for a reason
there's a certain line to that
i wouldn't really want to know who you
slept with or how many you slept with
you know
just
don't think that's right i'm interested
in your future that's it it's all
computers so if you were with a younger
woman like myself and i decided i wanted
to have children with you is that a
no-go or would you be like yeah i'm open
to it i'm open for it yeah really you
know why because i think if i could have
a son or a daughter younger than my
grandson our granddaughter and grandson
and granddaughter that'd be quite cool
and get loads of likes
no you can't do it for the likes
no i'm joking i'll say that to my family
yeah they're like dad you can't have
another kid how do they feel about it
actually they're all right they know
what i'm like you know they have to
control me now again my son dwayne is my
partner in ocean as well he's he's like
the father of a relationship yeah you
know and i'm like the son so he's always
telling me off he's always take him in
the office for a little chat really yeah
a blessing how would you caught a woman
so what's the process like how did you
chat a woman up i just try and make us
feel as special as i can oh obviously
well managed to open the door pull the
seat out the table pay the bill old
traditional stuff really so you're a
gentleman then i like to think i'm yeah
i like them to go home and thinking well
that was nice you know he's a nice guy
do you think the
like because obviously i've read things
about you in the press and stuff like
that and do you think people know the
real you i think they do now before i
went into celebs go dating i was posting
some controversial stuff and yeah a few
things backfired on me i was trending on
twitter like four times in one year um
but not for good things but bad things i
was getting abuse abuse from everywhere
i came out and slept go dating and a guy
called ali ross wrote an article in
in the sun he should change his name to
wayne kerr
he wrote a whole article about how i
shouldn't have been on celebs go daily
now i was this how was that i was like
so i posted it it went absolutely mad it
went viral like i've got 250 000 likes
and i've got so much support we started
a no excuse for abuse campaign i get
certain celebs like thomas and e and
chloe and callum and people like that to
come on the show and talk about abuse
how they deal with it and blah blah blah
and that was a real big success for me
it's a real move for me congratulations
oh man thank you because of the two
things combined celebs go dating and the
no excuse for exclusive campaign and all
the work that i do with charities down
syndrome especially they're now like
they could see me for actually who i am
yeah you seem like a really nice guy
thank you face and everything but the
way i would see it like probably just
like the public would and this is just
how i would project so don't take it
personally whenever i see an older man
dating a younger woman it gives kind of
like not the same that you're exploiting
women but that's what i would think
because i think usually is young girls
that have daddy issues that haven't had
father in their life that are dating
older men so that's why i would see the
flip and i'd be like oh hold on the
people i date are always over 25 day
whatever or around that age they're
fully grown women i don't go to the
conservative club i hang around 60 year
olds so i'm never in that environment to
ever get a connection with someone that
age you're telling me he's never dated a
woman over 30. my sister dated an older
guy and i know that when she brought him
home my dad wasn't too happy so how do
you find relationships with like the
women you're dating their fathers i've
heard that i've heard that several times
but eventually once they meet me they're
more than happy danielle's dad for
example was totally against it he told
me to my face he said i don't like this
and then when daniel and i split up he
was the one that was more upset than
anyone forget the age i think all
parents want is for their child to be
loved and respected by someone and i
think we do put a lot of pressure on two
people can have fun together and they're
attracted to each other it's a natural
thing the more you want to break that as
a parent the worse they're going to be
they're going to they're going to go
against it i think you're really nice
man thank you and the thing is for me
like say if i dated you and then walk
around i just would automatically think
people would assume that i'm with you
because of money lifestyle and i would
like a golden girl i think i think
people would think that's a fit [ __ ]
couple
yeah yeah [ __ ] right couple goals
yeah yeah absolutely but listen even
even guys come up to me and go why are
you why are you doing 30 year old i said
what you wouldn't do when you're 59. you
do good answer what'd you want to do you
went 30 year old well shut up then yeah
so when you was getting dragged online
and everything how did that affect your
mental health it only affected me
because of what my family thought it's
no secret garland because of my brother
you know i took it from an early age
you're only you're only doing this
because you're gary lincoln's brother
you've only got this because you're
gary's brother you only got this because
you gary's with her no
i'm doing my own thing so eventually
through the years i just got stronger
and stronger in my mental health but
what upsets me is that people that go on
to someone like love island all of a
sudden they've come out from with 500
followers to a million followers in the
public eye and it's too fast it's way
too fast which is why
you know people my good friends you know
have taken their own lives my ex my one
of my exes took her own life sophie
grady i'm really sorry after being on
the violin yeah which was really
upsetting for me because she got thrown
in from being not nobody but somebody
that wasn't known by the public as
someone all of a sudden super famous and
she got so much abuse from the press
she got so much abuse and i hate you
know it was too much for her so she took
her own life and that's really sad
that's the same with my
elites
um i had nando's with him two days
before he died does that cause like
friction in your relationships with your
family like obviously you said the
comparison with your brother or like you
you've got like your children your
grandchildren to protect does that cause
friction in the family none at all no
they're fully supportive of me your
family is your family
but they're if certain situations arise
how are we going to deal with it and you
know how we're going to speak about it
and do we speak about it do we just
ignore it and that sort of stuff yeah
but as a family unit we tend to make
them decisions together that's good i
think it's good that you've got like
that family yeah i'm very fortunate i'm
super fortunate yeah
obviously i'm attracted to you you're
very gorgeous woman thank you i i don't
know your situation you're mentally with
older men i guess you i'm the oldest
person you've ever had on this show by
putting lockwood yeah you are but is
there any attraction for you now you're
an attractive man i think you've got a
really nice energy about you so i'm
pleasantly surprised oh what's up you
later
i'm thinking that she's starting to like
me you know what's the wildest thing
you've ever done i don't think i should
tell you on my first date because she'll
be running out the door i might like it
what if i like wild the wildest thing
i've ever done trust me babe you
definitely don't want to know that and
my family definitely don't want to know
that and they'll be watching so
no way it's not going to happen i would
love to invite you to my 60th birthday
party which is um at ocean beach on the
24th of april oh my god
a lot of my friends at tomzanetti and
people out there are performing and yeah
it's going to be amazing but i love you
to come and i'll invite you on my table
he really wants me to come to this party
doesn't he okay i'll come to your sixth
year thank you cheers to that
we're talking about second dates here
i've invited us to the ultimate second
date which is my 60th birthday party
and i think she wants to come so where
are you from i was born in leicester i'm
raised in leicester i grew up with my
brother gary we were very close and we
spent you know every minute of the day
together so what was your upbringing
like when i worked on the markets fruit
and veg
as did my granddad and my great granddad
it was a very very thriving business
because there was no supermarkets then
so my dad
then asked me to start going to work on
the market through veg when i was 14
when i was 12 sorry
and every weekend i used to i used to
love it you know it was just it's a
great education for me as well i left
school at 14 didn't take anything five
days for my 14th 15th birthday by the
time i was 16 i'd had my own business by
the time i was 18 and 40 people working
for me wow my dad sort of stepped back
and let me take over by the time i was
20. then i was 26 and um then
supermarkets started opening then it
just overnight just went crashed and
then at that time my ex-wife dwayne and
sean's mum
she parents lived in
tenerife i said the market's done we
need to move to tenerife and at that
time my brother was so famous he was
captain of england he was just won the
golden boot in mexico and i thought to
myself i'm going to take advantage of my
second name i thought i know i do i live
in a bar and i'll call it linekers i
spoke to my brother he gave me full
blessing you know i had 40 grand in my
pocket i sold all my businesses
everything i mean 40 grand back then was
probably 200 grand now
and i put everything in i had into
trying to open a bar in in in las
america centenary we had to move from
that premises within six months because
it got too busy and um yeah it was a
huge success and uh it's just all been
built from there really and uh yeah so
when did you open ocean link has
expanded the brand we we opened in
several countries and we had a 14 at one
stage another partner in ocean now tony
truman called me and said i want to open
lunches in ibiza
which is my first introduction really to
abetha apart from going on holiday and
then tony called me said i found
after after the success of linux avitha
he called me he said when
because me and him had a conversation in
a pool in my bear saying we need to open
the beach club in ibiza but after that
he went back to the island called me
said wayne we've found the perfect spot
for ocean it was like oh my god it's too
big
we're like what the [ __ ] we're gonna do
with all this space we designed it and
built it it's now not big enough so tony
truman and dwayne really do all the work
and i take all the credit brilliant
which is nice
but yeah
me
[Laughter]
no
this is my husband
you're married no i said like when it's
my husband oh okay cool
perfect his face is like you're married
wait what did you say no i don't give
head you don't go down on women oh woman
yes
is it i'm i'm not up with a gang
definitely not on the first night babe
don't you think i'm asking you now no
i'm not
i'm just letting you know so how many
dates until you do i don't sleep with a
woman until i know
her on a personal level i really like
that i can't do it one night stands not
me sorry lads i don't wanna let you down
but it's not true i think i think men
could learn from you i i like it
she can have it all day
yes
yeah absolutely
really 100 i'm actually really surprised
i just believe if you've got a trust of
a woman you've got everything but if you
break that trust you're
and it's always forever don't care what
you say so i i class texting a guy or
texted a girl that's cheating if you're
flirting that's cheating that's just
your mother's going to sleep with them
yeah but until that trust is broken then
i've got no reason to ask you for your
phone but if you ask me for it i'll give
you because i've got nothing to hide i'm
strong on that i don't
trust is everything what if someone's a
natural flirt if you're if you're
floating in front of me and in a nice
way just being nice a little bit
flirtatious nothing wrong with that but
if you're floating behind my back i'm
waiting till i go and get a drink at the
bar then flirting oh yeah then that's
not cool but yeah i mean i'm a
flirtatious guy i'll float around people
in front of you but not in a no not a
disrespectful not in a disrespectful way
just because that's my character but if
you're out with me and you're flirting a
little bit having a bit laughed with the
guy it's no problem
especially if he's
not as good looking as me then if he's
really good looking like
you know what i mean it's a problem in
it no
i'm i'm a flirtatious guy i flirt around
my mates sometimes you know what i mean
do not
not really the same reason mine's
similar because i do and i don't i never
used to but now i just look and i think
what you've done in your past is your
own business you know what you do from
the day you met me is a different story
it's like a very mature answer i mean my
age come on
how am i gonna find a girl that's not
slept with everyone i understand that
she's gonna have to sleep with
people on our guys on our way to
a relationship with me so
i just don't want to know about them but
if there's too many then that's the
problem so say if you're out with your
friends and they're like oh so and so
she slept with loads of people
yeah i mean if she's you know she's
putting it about everywhere
that's different but you know if she's
had a reasonable about relationships and
she's slept with the guy every time
obviously i don't that's i've got no
problem with that
yeah what's your favorite thing to cook
um
sausage mashed peas gravy onion gravy
really oh it's the best i do like a
bananas and mash do come around for a
bang if you want both
the the food you supply the marshmallow
no bangs and match the foods
would you not i i'd just be embarrassing
myself you could fire around me no
problem not really sure about that one
um i'm happy with her fighting because i
think it's funny but me
i don't see anything attractive about me
flying around her when i'm comfortable
with someone i'm always farting like
around them
yeah just comfortable in it like let it
rip okay yes
so where are we going our next day
what's good in brentwood should we go
out now but now would you take me on
another date now i like that man is
prepared otherwise central london knobby
cough sexy fish vibe if you'd accept you
might june so she did ask me for a
second date all i can say is class
always shines through but yeah be nice
to get to know you're
away from the cameras nice vibes isn't
it good company i feel like all women
like to look nice as well like get
glammed up well i'm speaking for myself
i'll get your bits off as well ah proper
general man absolutely yeah does that
mean you want a second date yeah i'll
come on the second day oh yeah yeah
let's try new things i love that
or old things
you're funny
so what if i was to call you daddy in
the bedroom that's a good thing right
now is it good i've heard that if you
called the daddy that's the one in it is
it it could be maybe without it our age
difference might be a bit wet
yeah
you want to call me daddy granddaddy
whatever i'm both
so
whatever floats your boat babe i'm up
for it
what we call your daddy
because it's a good thing in it
you're the daddy bro
but if i said that what would you do
would you just like feel like i got dms
all the time from girls saying can you
be my daddy and i'm thinking that's
weird so have you actually ever called
someone daddy in the bedroom trying no
are you sure
what's like the weirdest thing someone's
messaged you
like how do they slide in your dms
it's sometimes just complete filth
really yeah like i've seen videos and
stuff but i've got a social media
manager she
all my request messages she looks at
that's great so i don't really see them
you think guys are bad girls are like
yeah it's mad babe when was the last
time you had sex
it's been a while summer last year
summer last year
yeah july or august so what have you
been doing since just celibacy like i
said from before i have to be
i can't just randomly sleep with girls i
just know it's just not in me i have to
have feelings for someone before i sleep
with them
unless i'm absolutely smashed and it's
different yeah
then i'm no good
yeah so mate it's march i hibernate in
the winter for a proper sexual
experience then i have to have a
relationship with that girl i'll know
them on a personal basis trust them so
any thoughts you've got this afternoon
just wait babe
any fools that i've got yeah i'm just
asking you just like don't get too
carried away i don't think i have a halo
on my head joking there's a halo can you
not see it believe it or not i'm not a
sex at all winter you you saying that
just to impress me no because i don't
think that oppresses you i think you
probably think
that's not cool why is he not why is it
not sex no i think that's quite cool
actually
i don't like a man that's like
everywhere no i've never been that man
interesting i mean sometimes it's hard
to say to the guys my mates you know
what i mean
it makes them more ladies what's wrong
with you there's nothing wrong with me
bro
so i just choose to just say oh yeah
shagdah
but do you say it just to kim kart would
you say it to be a part of like that do
you like that no i'll say it i say it
because i don't want them to think i'm
i'm like
inferior as it were yeah but you won't
be you're just being i know it's that a
typical lad's mind is like they just
want everything but you don't have to
give in to that you could be like yeah
no that's that big outfit that's
actually nice yeah maybe i mean one of
my close friends i am but you know in
the scottish guys they come up hey wayne
you're top shagger top shagger my hero
but they definitely must have seen you
shagging for them to give you that time
i just presume i'm a top shadow
listen how is he saying he doesn't have
sex and he's getting the title top
shagger i'm sure they must have just at
some point there must have been life
where you were just like shagging loads
for them to give you that time
they see me on social media surrounding
my girls every other day in my life
that they think i'm shugging them so why
don't you say actually no i'm not
because it will break their hearts break
their hearts then you care about that 16
lads wayne oh top shagger
i'm like when we're gonna go never shag
boys no well you could but you could you
could though because realistically like
for someone that's got like a father to
a daughter like because men that have
that laddish energy are just like
complete [ __ ] so when you've
actually got a man that's been a
gentleman actually this is the way lads
we don't just shag them and disrespect
them it's a lot better now maybe that's
maybe that's the route i should take now
yeah i think it is
a lesson
i was expecting you to groom me a lot
more than you have so i'll take that as
a positive because i've seen some of the
previous episodes i noted
um
so how's it been for you yeah i've
enjoyed myself it's nice i think it's
going really well guys
um
i'm definitely making moves there
what would you do if i've stuck with two
of your friends in the past that's a
no-no really yeah i think it's a code of
conduct with the boys you know if my
genuinely best mates have slept with
them then it's a no-go i think it'd be
the same for the boys depends how close
they are if if i had strong feelings for
it wouldn't break it forever now but
would it be weird to say like if i had
slept with them and then we're all out
for dinner because they're like you're
close friends no that not really i'll be
okay with that um because you had your
time and we've had we're having ours now
but it is a little bit weird because
it's my mate you know what i mean yeah
it wouldn't break the deal for me what
if my ex was after you in what way
trying to fight you it couldn't compete
i couldn't erect after me why would you
want to do that i'll just give him a
free tablet ocean he'll be happy i'll
probably ring him up i'll probably front
him and ask him to speak to me privately
and
sit down have a chat persuade him that
i'm not a bad person i'm not out to make
your life hell or his life hell so yeah
definitely decorum first
and then if he was continually
aggressive then that's another story but
you don't want me arguing with your ex
do you it's no fun is it i like that
replay what if i wanted to start an only
fans absolutely not why not
only fans
my children said to me dad um we need
you to be in a relationship you've been
single enough for two years and we're
worried about you you're getting loose
again and blah blah blah so i said okay
find me find me a girl they didn't so
what you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna
post my criteria i'm gonna i'm gonna
find out who wants me like a job
application they have to match my
criteria better get your cvs in ladies
and one of them on it was i don't have
only fans you shouldn't too okay and the
reason for that is because every single
time i meet an only fans girl which i've
got nothing against because it's a great
way of making income if you're going to
be my girlfriend and you're slapping
your stuff around on live webcam and
this that and the other and i just don't
think it's survive
so i don't do it so i don't think you
should only fans will be absolutely no
no for me what if i got put in prison
for five years would you wait for me
absolutely 100 yeah woody wait though
listen if you're going ocean every
summer you ain't waiting you'd wait that
means like
no sex 100 i've been in prison so love
you yeah really yeah sweden why'd you go
to prison sex
how long four i did seven half months
really
wow i didn't know that he's been to
prison
i didn't know that yeah another
girlfriend at the time stood by me it
was a really tough time but it was
ridiculous only went to prison because i
was gary's brother at the time
so they set an example of me but but if
you went to prison i'd 100 stick by
unless you got
life yeah
five years you're out in two and a half
years good behavior yeah exactly happy
days what if i didn't sleep with you for
the first six months six months a bit
long three months i'd i'd respect you
any more than that i'd be thinking she's
not attracted to me that way does that
change the way you would respect women
so if i slept with you after
like
two weeks
to instead of waiting six months would
you view me differently yeah i think
after two weeks it's fine it depends how
much you've seen each other if if it's
first night second night third night
then there wouldn't be a long-term
relationship because i'd lose my respect
for you i still like yourself though
i've got a feeling someone and i can't
get them over one night yeah take some
time but not too much because they're
like so there's a fine line it just then
goes into like the friend zone and then
yeah
yeah exactly that what if i wanted to
involve other people into our sex life
can i pick what sets there yeah okay
woman yes ma'am no i'm happy you sleep
with a woman i'm all over that really
yeah it's cool i'm going to make you
feel inferior because it's like a woman
knows a woman's body yeah i love that so
you just sit and watch yeah i'm happy
content
out of a cigar
what if your friends were liking all my
pictures love that do you yeah yeah show
them listen this is mine right this is
my that's my mrs mate
if they weren't liking them i'd be like
why are you not liking my mrs picks man
she's fit bro you're funny what would
you do if i couldn't cook i'll cook for
you would you that was smooth would you
say you're smooth oh i'll take you out
for dinner most of the time i like to
eat a lot what if like
one is a traditional woman though in the
home i don't want traditional woman the
last thing i want is a woman at home
cooking me breakfast cooking me lunch
cooking dinner i need my clothes there's
something like that what do you want
then i wanted to come out with me let's
go out let someone else do that for us
your dream i think when you've got kids
though
that's like nice to be at obviously if
you've got children then you but you
both have to
put the effort into that you know it's
not just one it's not just a mum you
know so you both you know you have to
play your part
but still i don't want you in the
kitchen every night and just certainly
this you know so now do you just want to
enjoy life now i guess just enjoy life
go out be happy but i'm also not
naive enough to know that if i meet a
younger woman
that which is what i'm attracted to
um
30ish
calm down if she wants a baby then i'm
not going to be
ignorant enough to say i'm not i'm not
that place you know we would i would gen
generally try not just for the likes not
just for the likes
would you get married again yeah
have you been married i just said again
and presumably twice twice
third time lucky yeah exactly that would
you make him sign a pronoun no no
i'll be dead by the time you split up
anyways
no there's certain things in laws now
where you you'll be protected anyway
everything that i've got now goes to my
children and it works
as it should yeah
wayne how do you think you've done on
the day i've smiled all the time so i
know i've seen you smile a lot so i
think you've enjoyed my company and i've
certainly enjoyed yours whether there's
any attraction there for you i don't
know i've had a great time and uh it's
been nice to get to know you yeah it's
been a nice day
cool
cheers to the date cheers to the date
that was a good day
pleasantly surprised i've had a really
good time um i found her to be really
fun and attractive and
good banter yeah he definitely handled
the questions well because i feel like
he's older and wiser so he knows exactly
how to respond to my questions started
off a little bit
niggly but um i think i went around in
the end she definitely won me around i
really like her what do you think you'd
write yourself
out of ten i'll leave that for her to
decide but i'm guessing around six or
seven you know what i've really enjoyed
the day i feel like he dressed well he's
like a gentleman
and the conversation went really well
like it flowed nice however there wasn't
that much chemistry so i'm gonna give
wayne a 6.5
you